[Musique]
le plastique c'est merci chanter en 1990
le groupe
elmer food beat que les moins de vingt
ans ne peuvent pas connaître
hier encore le plastique avaient toutes
les vertus solide léger isolant
transparent film abl imperméable
protecteur et il est absolument partout
autour de nous pour nous rendre service
mais aujourd'hui chanter le plastique
c'est fantastique serait un brin
provocateur et pourtant ce matin
peut-être être vous allez dans un
supermarché
j'aurais pu vous lancer un défi trouver
un mètre linéaire de rayons sans
plastique
le plastique est idéale par exemple pour
conserver nos aliments sains viandes
poissons
m
savez vous combien de tonnes de
nourriture sont jetés chaque année une
idée 1,3 milliard de tonnes 30 % de la
production mondiale sans plastique
ce chiffre terrible serait encore plus
dramatique
je vois ici de jeunes parents aux mines
fatiguées
auriez vous messieurs mesdames choisi
des couches lavables utiliser ma grand
mère plutôt que ces couches au plastique
adsorbants qui aurait laissé les fesses
de votre chérubin toute sèche
arrivé aux caisses d'un élan écolo vous
choisissez des sacs en papier
par chance il ne pleuvait pas ce matin
mais attention le diable se cache
souvent dans les détails
êtes vous si sûr que le papier soit plus
écologique que le plastique
je vous laisse vérifier mais prenez bien
en compte
l'eau l'énergie consommée le co2 produit
et vous aurez peut-être une surprise
vous êtes j'imagine venus en voiture
aujourd'hui 30 % de son poids est en
plastique
elle pèse donc 200 kg de moins que votre
précédente voitures moins gourmandes en
carburant
elle produit donc moins de co2 plutôt
positif pour notre climat
ne trouvez-vous pas et vous voilà
maintenant ici confortablement installés
dans ces fauteuils en plastique vos
lunettes madame en plastique votre
smartphone monsieur est un j'espère en
plastique votre chemisier une grande
partie de votre costume en plastique
vous auriez pu choisir un matériau plus
naturelle du coton par exemple mes choix
cornélien savez vous que pour produire
un kilogramme de coton
il faut cinq mille litres d'eau je
pourrais multiplier les exemples et
chanter avec vous le plastique c'est
merci mais vous conviendrez avec moi que
l'homme a passé son temps à faire des
folies à produire produire et produire
encore des millions de tonnes de
plastique nous en consommons 400
millions de tonnes chaque année 150
millions de tonnes deviennent des
déchets et beaucoup finissent enfouies
ou incinérées avec ma compagne au mois
de mars nous aident mire y ont ravi la
baie d'along au viêtnam spectacle
idyllique mais quelque peu gâchée par
toutes ces bouteilles
ces sacs et autres horreurs qui
jonchaient la mer 9 millions de tonnes
de plastique finissent chaque année dans
nos mères et nos océans formant le
tristement célèbre septième continent
cela fait un camion de 18 tonnes toutes
les secondes sans une prise de
conscience collective en 2050
demain donc il y aura dans nos océans
plus de plastique que deux poissons et
je pourrais vous parler des heures du
problème des micro plastiques qui
affecterait notre santé le plastique
hier adulé est aujourd'hui décriée à tel
point que des esprits chagrins voudrait
le supprimer je suis un scientifique je
m'attache toujours à poser sur les
plateaux de la balance le pour et le
contre
c'est une question d'équilibré
supprimer le plastique impossible selon
moi mieux le gérer
il le faut trouver une fin de vie
acceptable c'est absolument nécessaire
tout comme vous j'imagine je me sens de
plus en plus concerné par l'écologie
je me déplace en vélo j'économise l'eau
je respecte les consignes de tri
je traite mes puis avec un produit
biologique et au désespoir de ma femme
et de nos enfants j'ai même imposé des
toilettes sèches dans notre maison de
campagne
imaginez mon métier
chercheur en biologie parfois trouveurs
une prothèses osseuses autorise
générative un antiarythmique cardiaque
mais je lave ou rien ne me prédestinait
à apporter ma pierre pour trouver une
solution à la fin de vie des plastiques
et pourtant maintenant c'est cette
histoire que je vais vous raconter
le hasard fait bien les choses
en juin 2011 jean claude a déboulé dans
mon laboratoire en toulousain avec une
folle ambition en tête qu'il avait eue
en se promenant sur son cher vieux port
de marseille n'ont pas bouché par une
sardine mais j'en ch et de plastique
l'idée était simple suivez moi bien être
joaillier être plasturgiste c'est un
fabricant de plastique c'est un peu
comme être un joaillier un fabricant de
collier on prend des perles de couleurs
différentes
ap les monomères et on les assemble une
bleue une rouge une bleue et ainsi de
suite on fait un collier l'écolier
s'entrelacent et cela fait du plastique
l'idée géniale trouver un ciseaux pour
couper le plastique libéré les perles
évidemment le ciseau doit être
microscopiques
nous aurions pu choisir un ciseau
chimiques agissant dans un solvant
organique
nous avons préféré opter pour un ciseau
biologique une enzyme agissant dans de
l'eau purificatrice une enzyme késako ce
sont les protéines qui au sein de toutes
nos cellules catalyse les milliers de
réactions nécessaires à la vie rendez
vous compte
juste retour des choses dame nature se
défendant contre le plastique
un jour après des années d évolution
elle sera capable de se défendre tout
seul
j'en suis convaincu mais le temps presse
il a fallu un peut l'aider
notre premier objectif est de rendre
biodégradables un plastique nous
appelons paix est là qui sert à faire
des sacs de caisse des films de paillage
en agriculture des verts des couverts
jetables
l'idée introduire notre petit ciseau
dans tranzyme directement dans le
plastique pour que après usage
elle se biodégrade mais comment jean
claude me répondit mais c'est fort
simple on introduira notre enzymes lors
de la fabrication du plastique à l'état
font du très bien mais cela fonds à
quelle température le pl à 170° me
répondit-il 170° là nous avions un vrai
problème car la nature a fabriqué les
enzymes pour travailler à température
ambiante alors 170 degrés impossible
pour moi d'imaginer une enzyme résistant
à cet enfer mais comment dire
vous connaissez pas jean-claude non
jean claude est têtu est prêt à dépenser
quelques euros pour rendre possible
l'impossible alors nous sommes tournés
une deuxième fois vers dame nature qui
possède des ressources incroyables
certains microorganismes très spéciaux
vivent dans des sources chaudes sous
marine à des températures largement
supérieur à 100 degrés on peut donc
supposer que leurs enzymes sont capables
de résister à des températures très
élevées dans un de ces micro-organismes
très spéciaux nous avons trouvé un petit
ciseau pour dégrader le pl a
il n'était pas bien efficace notre
saison ça fonctionnait pas très bien
mais c'était quand même une bonne base
pour exercer mon second métier
serrurier serrurier très spécial ma clé
dans ce cas là un bout de plastique ma
serrure le site d'arrimage du plastique
dans l'enzyme mon objectif que ma
serrure soit le mieux adapté à ma clé
mais outils des ordinateurs surpuissants
des lunettes 3d quelques éprouvettes et
quelques pitt est alors avec mes
collègues toulousains nous nous sommes
attelés à la tâche
nous avons passé des jours entiers et
même des nuits blanches
retouchant le dessin de la zone
d'arrimage du galbe de l'enzyme nous
avons passé des heures autour d'un café
crème à discuter des meilleures
stratégies et puis un jour après
d'infini efforts des tâtonnements des
questionnements notre ciseau est devenu
absolument redoutable pour le plastique
est capable de résister à l'enfer des
170 degrés et quelle ne fut pas notre
joie un jour de voir un sac plastique
contenant notre enzymes se dégrader peu
à peu jusqu'à disparaître dans le
compost au fond de mon jardin pour le
plus grand plaisir des micro-organismes
se régalant des perles ainsi libérés
fort de ce premier succès nous sommes
attaqués un problème beaucoup plus
important celui des 500 milliards de
bouteilles d'eau et de sodas que nous
consommons chaque année 500 milliards
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
un chiffre tellement gigantesque ce que
c'est difficile de l'imaginer
alors laissez moi faire un petit calcul
500 milliards jeudi par 365 puis par 24
par 60 par 60
cela fait cela fait soixante mille
bouteilles consommées chaque seconde
si nous prenions toutes les bouteilles
produites par une célèbre marque de soda
mises bout à bout cela ferait 2500 aller
retour terre lune près de 2 milliards de
kilomètres ces bouteilles sont faites
dans un plastique dont peut-être vous
connaissez le nom
le pt le ptc fabriqué à partir de deux
mois au maire aujourd'hui grâce à nos
poubelles jaunes
nous savons le collecter donc pourquoi
gâcher et le donner aux micro organismes
nous avons choisi de recycler les
bouteilles
ici aussi l'idée était fort simple on
collecte les bouteilles un petit coup de
mixeur on met les fragments dans un
grand chaudron un peu d'eau
purificatrice un fifrelin d'une deuxième
azim amoureusement optimisé dans notre
laboratoire
on met à feu doux au bout de quelques
heures
le plastique a disparu et au fond du
chaudron nom de monomères le tour est
joué
les plasturgistes pourront refaire du
plastique puis refaire des bouteilles et
en plus
cela fonctionne pour nos vieux vêtements
en polyester
maintenant il nous reste à transformer
l'essai comme on dit à toulouse
peut-être en hormones aussi transformer
un succès scientifiques en des usines et
des emplois les premiers films
plastiques biosourcés biodégradables et
compostables verront les jours le jour
début 2000 20 la première unité de
recyclage de bouteilles en 2021 alors
peut-être avez-vous l'idée une image un
peu ancien du chercheur travaillant tout
seul au fond de ceux de son laboratoire
mais je voudrais vous dire que ben 1-1
alliant les forces on est plus efficace
et donc nous avons été 50 à travailler
sur ce projet mais vous tous ici vous
avez votre rôle d'abord en respectant
les consignes de tri
aujourd'hui seuls 30% des ménages
respecte correctement les consignes de
tri
et puis peut-être lors de vos achats en
privilégiant les produits recyclés alors
dans ces conditions nous pourrons
continuer à chanter le plastique c'est
fantastique et un monde chante déchets
plastiques c'est for me formidable
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]